I said to you take that off that's too
revealing are you going to change are
you going to argue I will question it so
you're going to argue I would argue
that's how they see it
[Music]
I'll crush it and try to understand
depending on the occasion of why you're
telling me to take it off because if I'm
going if I go now out why can't I skin
out and I would argue a little bit
because yeah
jealousy as well so I would argue but
then I'll still go out with the same
outfit
too bad
makes all of you toxic because you just
said you'd be okay with submission but
when he told you what to do you're gonna
argue I mean when it comes to telling
someone what to do like telling me I
can't wear a certain outfit because it's
too revealing like
he wants to protect you it's like but
the thing is is he protecting me from
other men or is he insecure and not
comfortable with me going out because
other men are gonna look at me
if you have a nice car I mean are you
gonna put a for sale sign on it are you
gonna advertise
yeah
what is submission to you guys
I think submission is just being a
feminine woman like I really like in a
man yeah when he can like not take
control of me but take control of
certain situations so like say if we
like plan to go somewhere he planned it
or he can like make decisions for
himself but also for the both of us but
like within reason like certain
decisions like need to be communicated
between like both Partners yeah but like
yeah because we're both human that is no
submission okay so what's the submission
I think submission is when
um the the female is very much in her
well somebody that's what she said but
let's do that's the guy that kind of um
take control and sometimes in some
situations I'm not sexy that's more
attractive yeah I love that make me feel
petite
let me know like the Damsel in this
dress
so for you guys submission is a bit more
sexual I didn't get to answer that but
submission is um about him by the rules
of your um opposite sex so when he says
oh yeah don't wear that you're literally
saying
some something like yes sir I'm not
gonna do it because you have your
reasons to why I'm not even questioning
it because but you guys just said right
now that you will not do it I mean it
depends like if you're wearing a dress
and you're like your nipples I'm just
answering your questions
but if it's like a little mini dress and
you're going to the club of your girls
then I don't see why it should be an
issue but then like if it's like
something super like your ass cheeks are
hanging out your nipples are popping out
so that's okay we walk then let fair
enough
as a man is gonna is there to lead his
family he has a vision for his family so
if he says in my family in my household
we don't wear that you're supposed to be
like okay yeah yeah but if you guys are
what you're saying is no uh there's some
things you can decide but you say
something yeah I said I said I'm a
Christian occasion I understand the
reason why I mean there's always
compromise so what do you think being
submissive actually if then is this your
only one definition
you should actually just system you
can't even question it that's what we
expect what does submit mean to you
because I thought we stated it I feel
like I feel like that stems off
Traditions guys the definition the death
wait the definition is the action of
accepting or yielding to a superior
force or to the will or authority of
another person so abiding by his rules
so I'm gonna decide whether or not if I
should abide by his rules
what do you think what do you think okay
and women should actually be equal but
obviously let them make some of the
decisions I guess it's about about
balance you can't just say oh I'm gonna
oh he's a superior worship him
into account um I don't know how old you
are but like if you're an older guy
you're gonna have slightly different
like values like as a 20 year old 22
year old sorry
we want to go out and like have fun you
know we'll wear our little tight dress
[Laughter]
what do you think works modern dating or
old-fashioned dating old-fashioned I
personally I like old-fashioned okay
how how do you expect old-fashioned
outcomes in traditional courting and
traditional outcomes if you don't want
to act like a traditional women in
traditional women submit I don't know do
I no
if it works it works no but it's like
say for example like obviously like an
older woman she's not really like she's
going to dress a bit more maturely like
she's going to be more modest and stuff
I feel like in today's generation yeah
when we're young we always want to be
skin out and like wear these little
booty shorts why not look at me right
now if you've got it show it off
yeah but that's the mindset of like the
modern day generation like back in the
day like the housewives were not going
to the club and that is
I will say that you're not gonna get
like a you say traditional outcomes yeah
of course it clashes with the new like
you don't know of course it is because
you guys even when you're saying oh I'll
question him and ask him about the if
your boss gives you an order at work you
can't and your boss says hey this is the
uniform do you question him so why do we
question like why do we question we not
question our bosses but we're going to
question the person that we want to make
a family with I do question my boss
I question my boss why do I need to and
I'm sure you're his favorite employer I
actually am because I'm honest I feel
like that all depends on the types that
you give him as in you can actually make
your own definition of what a boyfriend
or a friend or a family or Mom or Dad
could be
explain that again it all depends on the
title that you give them all depends on
how you see them as in you can make your
own rules as you go
um
if you want to lead the relationship
sure but like do women typically end up
happy when they're making the decisions
and making the rules and leading the
relationship because we allow our
emotions so so it's kind of like you
guys are saying you want your cake and
you also want to eat it too
[Laughter]
so do you want every every single
decision you guys have a conversation
about yeah like you said every single
does that seem like an efficient way to
do things marriages aren't going to be
perfect the same way being boyfriend
girlfriend ain't gonna be perfect so
it's like that is leading up to it
that's the hope I'm not I'm not saying
it's going to be perfect but at the end
of the day when you guys disagree
someone has to make a decision
someone has to give right there's always
going to be someone who's gonna give
there's always right and then two should
and and typically what I see nowadays is
is the man gives more he gives up more
and then we say the woman wears the
pants in the relationship no I agree
with that and so but the woman usually
hates the man when she's in a
relationship where she has to wear the
pants
yeah yeah
investors that were
there you know you you're thinking of
someone I can see it in your face like
the ones that make all the decisions in
the relationship that are wet their
boyfriends whipped they hate their
boyfriend yeah they shouldn't even be in
a relationship
the mentality the mentality you guys
have that's where you're going yeah no
do you know what though I feel like when
you really love a man and you fall into
it you naturally do become awesome
when you like fall in love with someone
and you get into a relationship with
them you do naturally as a woman become
more submissive I don't know like for
every woman that's the same with me like
because because
you become more feminine
do you think that men are feminine until
they meet the right woman no so I
thought I become feminine afterwards
after they meet the right women because
you're with the women all day and you
are who you're surrounded by actually
going back to what you said I feel like
the only reason why a woman put up that
old toxic masculinity is by them
protecting themselves so they don't get
hurt yeah I agree with that that's true
it's a protection explain that again
so people um girls act bad and the
reason why they act like a guy is is
because
they're literally protecting them so I
don't know how else to like yeah because
they don't want to feel that hurt again
that goes to the concept it's like
you're making the men of the future pay
for the mistakes of your past yeah if
you carry it with you yeah if you're
acting like a dude so you don't get hurt
I mean like how many times do guys act
like girls so they don't get hurt
yeah but you've gone through that those
past
um experienced relationships to shape
who you are who are meant to become so
when you meet the right person you're
not going to be able to fall into the
same track
that's why yeah yeah
I mean there's a difference between
being naive and being traumatized
so so it's one thing if you're naive
right you can I can understand that
maybe not being so naive but it's a
different thing when you're bringing
your trauma into your yeah I don't like
the word trauma I don't like the word
trauma
nonsense
relationship experience into your
baggage yeah your baggage into your
future but it's like
you know how how do we move forward with
men and like actually get together and
get along with them if we don't trust
them well I think again like if you have
a lot of baggage that self-reflection
and self-heating that you have to do in
order for you to be in a situation
because if you get into a relationship
and you have a [__] ton of baggage and
then you're pushing all of that baggage
onto that person who wants a
relationship with you and now they're
carrying your baggage as well as you it
becomes an unhealthy environment what
does healing look like oh I think no
one's fully healed okay but I think I
think through life everyone is healing
constantly constantly things are going
on in life and people heal from things
every single day you're never fully
healed like there's no definition of
being oh I'm Healed like I'm a healed
person yeah but if you wanted to take
steps to heal I would definitely look at
self-reflection self-reflection see the
things that have triggered me or things
that have caused me issues in the past
and how can I grow from that and how can
I work towards improving them so these
triggers don't affect me anymore and I
don't bring this baggage into future
relationships or push my own
insecurities and issues onto other
people because of my past experiences
what about therapy therapy is good but
therapy only works if you're willing to
do therapy if you go to therapy and you
don't want to do therapy then it's not
going to work for you I've just I've
done a lot of these shows and I just
found when girls say self-reflection
it's like nothing it's like listen to
some read some books put on some candles
listen to something I think
self-reflection I think journaling is
really important to write down how you
feel so then you can look back on it and
reflect on it and be like okay I felt
like this today yeah this is what I did
I might have acted out of character or
done this because again like looking
inwards is difficult it's difficult to
realize
and you see it from another perspective
almost yeah yeah you're reading the
story but it's your story yeah you know
I mean I also feel like allow yourself
to go through whatever has hurt you in
the past yeah you have to face the most
painful thing you could ever do allow
yourself to go through that again feel
those emotions that you felt when you
went through that you know so then you
could reflect from it Grow from it and
acknowledge it and so you can see like
how much you've changed I'm sure you
must have grown from that moment as well
so it's nice to sometimes look back and
think all my days I used to be like this
but now I'm like this John from the same
so again journaling in aspect is good
yeah to overcome uh blessing did you
have any more questions about submission
for them I feel like you had another one
but I'm gonna cut you off
yeah now I'm just gonna conclude and say
that we look for submission because
submission brings peace and if you guys
are not gonna submit to us we're not
gonna have peace and then one piece and
if he's snoring he's snoring
well
what if what if your wife for example
feels like what if your wife for example
feels like what you're saying doesn't
really align with what she believes to
be right or true
do you feel like that's her going
against you or that's her well for me
personally I would question it I'd be
like okay so why I wouldn't necessarily
want to have an argument I wouldn't
necessarily want to go against what
you're saying I just want to understand
from your perspective how has that
favored you in the past
um that that means that you're not
compatible that means you don't have the
same vision and you're not aligned I'm a
Christian and and there's a Christian
there's a story in the Bible about
Abraham who basically had a conversation
with God and he told him to just go
and that was just between him and God
and he had to take his wife his wife
didn't know where he was going and she
just followed that submission she
trusted her yeah trust and bring
submission so if you don't have that
that means you just maybe just you're
just not compatible
okay I actually agree with that
okay I do to an extent
what's your name again blessing you have
you're truly a blessing
truly a blessing at the end of the day I
think the main goal for a lot of people
is just peace you don't want to argument
you don't want toxicity exactly you know
exactly yeah didn't we start the show
and like we said you like toxicity
I have changed so much about this
podcast literally
right I've come from you know whatever
that's in the past now actually no sorry
to be the person but you can have peace
and someone can stay cheap behind your
back and just make it seem as if yeah
it's normal as long as I'm with you
you're gonna let it affect you because
you know you won't let it affect you
because you don't want to eat pizza
there's different scenarios you can be
at peace but the guys through doing
stuff that I shouldn't be doing and
you're just being submissive you get it
so it's like yeah but it could go the
other way around too I mean like he
could like she could be doing stuff that
she's not supposed to be doing well but
like it's like as women were always
bringing up the worst case scenarios
it's like what could go wrong instead of
what could go right I agree with that
100 I think we have a very very negative
mindset when we get into relationships a
lot of people like oh what if he cheats
on me what if he does this or he's
sneaky is that why don't you just look
at the point is that because of like
what Society reveals to us and you think
that they make men to be these villains
I think social media places
there's a reason there's a reason why we
think like this we don't just think like
this like that out of nowhere but you
know what I think it depends what kind
of content you consume on social media
okay the popular culture yeah is very
very toxic like constantly that people
couples arguing people get influenced by
it right you're saying if you don't
watch that if you don't watch that then
you're not going to get influenced by it
like social media is a platform yeah and
you can choose what like what you want
to absorb and what you don't but what
you absorb it does have an effect on you
whether you think it or not like
subconsciously it does affect you I
definitely I consume some really bad
stuff
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible